شغف بيتزا بالكاري أو دجاج مقلي ،
ربما يكون بوريتو على مكتبك ربطة عنق أثناء صعودك على
متن رحلة أو برجر يتم توصيله
بواسطة طائرة بدون طيار ، نعم عن طريق توصيل الرجال الآليين بالطائرة
قد قطعت شوطًا طويلاً منذ
أيام القوائم الورقية المحشوة أسفل
بابك.
الذهاب إلى آفاق جديدة في
دبي وجذب بعض مشاهد الطعام ،
توصيل أكبر اللاعبين هو
أسلوب حياة هنا ، بينما في أوروبا
والأسواق الأخرى ، كان الأمر أكثر
رفاهية كوننا نعيش بنسبة 80 ٪
ولكن هل قمت بالفعل بتسليم
الهامبرغر  مع هذه الطائرات بدون طيار بالفعل ،
نتعامل مع اثنتين من
أكبر نقاط الألم وهي
كيف يمكنني أن أتأكد من
أنني أعرف الطعام عندما أحتاجه ،
دبي ليست مدينة مبنية
للمشي فقط عبر  قد يكون الشارع هنا
صعبًا ، فأنت تعلم ما هو حار جدًا ، إنه
صعب للغاية ، سأحصل على
الطعام الذي سيأتي إلي بدلاً من ذلك ، هناك
انفجار في تطبيقات وخدمات الطعام في
جميع أنحاء العالم ، لكن دبي تبرز بنسبة 60 في
المائة  يستخدم المستهلكون الإماراتيون تطبيقًا
لطلب الطعام مقارنة بـ 28٪ فقط في
المملكة المتحدة ، إنه سوق مزدحم
ويزداد انشغالًا فقط مع العلامات التجارية المألوفة مثل
تجربة التوصيل مع
أساليب جديدة تتجاوز التسليم ، والآن
يتوسعون مع المفهوم الجديد الذي يجعل
مساحات المطبخ  متاح للطهاة الجدد
أو المطاعم التي تتطلع إلى توسيع
نطاق التوصيل الخاص بهم ، لذا فهي عبارة عن مجموعة من
المطابخ المخصصة لعدد قليل من الشركاء ، فإن
burrata مدهش ، لذا كنتم مطعمًا ،
ولكن بعد ذلك ، لتكونوا جزءًا من إضافات التوصيل ،
قررت أن تكون مجرد
مطبخ داخل هذا  المساحة صحيحة ، لذلك
نحن ندفع تكاليف عامة باهظة
مثل الإيجار والتوظيف ، ومن
المدهش حقًا أن مبيعات الفن بدأت في
النمو مرة أخرى منذ أن انتقلنا إلى مطبخ Libero ،
إنه سوق تسليم ناضج ،
فالعمالة الأولى غير مكلفة نسبيًا
و B هي الحرارة و
تقرض البنية التحتية للطرق نوعًا ما لجعلها
أكثر ضرورة ، لذا فإن المطعم
الذي يميلون إلى تقديمه جيدًا عند التسليم في
دبي يميل أيضًا إلى أن يكون أكثر يومًا بعد يوم
الأشياء الصحية اليومية قد يبدو سوق التوصيل
مشبعًا ، لكن حتى اللاعبين المحليين ،
مثل تطبيق النقل السريع Kareem ،
أول شركة تكنولوجية ناشئة تبلغ قيمتها مليار دولار في الشرق الأوسط ،
تتطلع للحصول على شريحة
من الكعكة على مدار الشهرين الماضيين
، لقد اختبروا تطبيقًا جديدًا  خدمة الطعام
على أمل اختراق هذا
السوق المزدحم بالفعل ما يجعل سوق دبي
فريدًا من نوعه ، حيث يطلب المقيم العادي في دبي
الطعام أكثر من مرة في الأسبوع حتى
تعرف أن مساحة توصيل الطعام
شيء مهم جدًا بالنسبة لنا في
دبي مكان رائع لاختباره
إنها بيئة عمل ودودة للغاية
وأنت تعرف مكانًا رائعًا
لفهمه حقًا ثم توسيعه
، ونحن نتحدث عن سكان في
الشرق الأوسط الأكبر يبلغ عددهم 600 مليون
شخص بالإضافة إلى أن التوصيل شائع جدًا هنا
تفكر الشركات باستمرار في طرق جديدة
للمضي قدمًا من توصيل
هتافات بيجو إلى السماء ، قابل رجل التوصيل الجديد ،
لا يعلق في
حركة المرور بسرعة كبيرة ولا يتعين عليك تقديم
إكرامية عندما تفعل ذلك  أعتقد أننا سنرى في الواقع
طائرات بدون طيار تنقل الهامبرغر يتم استخدامها
بانتظام في السنوات الخمس إلى العشر القادمة ،
فإن موقع طائرة بدون طيار تحلق في
السماء سيثير
اهتمامك بك مثل سيارة تسير في الشارع
ولكن هل قمت بالفعل بتسليمها
الهامبرغر مع هذه الطائرات بدون طيار
فعلنا ذلك بالفعل لعميل كان يدير
حدثًا لمدة 20 يومًا على الشاطئ ، قمنا بتسليم
أكثر من 900 برجر في يوم واحد إلى الموظفين
في مدينة حيث يأتي الطعام إلى
العميل بدلاً من الطريقة الأخرى
في دبي.  أصبح ملعبًا
للشركات المحلية والعالمية التي تتنافس جميعها
لتقديم العشاء
[موسيقى]